[Music]
competition breeds rivalry sometimes
it's between organizations their
legacies evolving with every exchange
Ichiro's to SK Telecom a rivalry that
transcends League of Legends tries to
clean up for you oh look at the class
look at the bows thank you
why was that sometimes it's two
competitors at the peak of their powers
trading boys this has been nicknamed the
dream final so many players have been
waiting for a final such as this one
with two people who just seem to be
unbeatable and it's almost gone he takes
it out and the SCB making the other
starport Jaina is still in control of
this game
flash is falling apart fans but
sometimes a rivalry is built from
something else a difference in mindset a
casual Emma T born from a lack of
respect when huh can injure clashed in
the early 2010 it was the fresh-faced
new hope against the grizzled
foul-mouthed brood war veteran and it
was always worth watching the void rates
all hallucinations doing absolutely no
damage whatsoever
hey but before we get into it if you
want this sweet kappa shirt from our
what is series or plenty of other the
forty-fourth branded shirts just like it
you can check out the score esports
merch department which you can find a
link to in the comments below
ladies and gentlemen let's introduce our
next player
known as the Kraken from Team Evil
Geniuses Indra Gregg Indra Fields has
long been a foreigner in a game
dominated by Koreans he even moved to
the country and joined Korean teams like
East row and CJ entus by the time
Starcraft rolled around a juror was the
foremost foreigner and breeder but inter
became known for something else too
being unafraid to speak his mind [ __ ]
talking on ladder and generally pushing
the limits of sportsmanship let's go sit
down to the bat discuss tariff tariff
that's that's actually all
it's just awful all right what do you
think about cruncher and how do you
think this match is gonna go I'm playing
really bad but it's more than enough to
beat him all right guys well shake hands
if you're going to and let's go ahead
and in the booth guys as competition in
the West mostly shifted towards
Starcraft to a new breed of foreign
hopes arose and one among them Chris
Loranger showed promise this week you
are actually in the final so how do you
feel about that
I feel great I mean this is my second
land of all time so the experience is
definitely adding up
ESL it was a real challenge for me just
because it was my first land hopefully I
continue to do well he boasted a strong
win-loss record during the games of beta
period which earned him tournament
invites in a chance to play for Team
millenium I do want to continue to
emphasize that fact about Huck the
faculties just laid back and he's very
embracing of all the situations he's in
he doesn't even think of himself as like
the best player in the world he's always
asking players for advice and when he
loses games and we've even seen in
reviews games and Hitler tends to say oh
that's a terrible strategy you'll never
get far doing that but Huck says god I
can't believe you beat me that badly I
gotta figure out how to not make that
happen to us and he literally says it
like that I've seen him do it in private
practice games with other players his
style was aggressive and unpredictable
switching between standard builds and
more unpredictable strategies like the
mothership rush just spent his gas on a
flea beacon mothership rush
really wait he's actually gonna do it
are you kidding me
with Jimmy going for this fast expand
build he's not gonna oh my god
but while he was hyped during the beta
Huck fell short and his first post
release Lyon in Cologne exiting the
tournament in the group stage he bounced
back quickly taking first place at MLG
Raleigh 2010 and she gonna be enough
[ __ ] winning that series decisively and
Huff with the Grand Champion here at MLG
Raleigh let's give another round of
applause for our champion Huck the
grizzled veteran and the rising star
Indra and Huck were on a collision
course the two faced off at MLG DC 2010
no way that it's going to come out and
that will stop it at bay or Jessie who
would have thought you can see a spine
crawler push at the 12-minute mark of
the game the probes are now pulling off
there's very little that Huck can do
about this yet and their game
Wow people like to say Ezra is a macro
oriented player the battle stroke of
genius Stratos Idris and Huck who had
recently joined Team Liquid to the
loser's bracket with a 2o drumming their
against select puck tried out one of the
tricks who's becoming known for the
mothership rush but it didn't work out
and Indra ended up taking the whole
tournament for evil geniuses
so Holly [ __ ] or for poster boy for
Starcraft 2 eSports don't agree but
since the community's [ __ ] Huck made
the he brought in the audience they
laugh was great he threw the game away
even though the mothership failed and
Indra had won the tournament the move
brought attention to Huck and burned him
fans in the nascent Starcraft 2 see
tough loss to Indra again at eg Masters
Cup Series three with injured displaying
some serious BM as he attacked with his
drones and started building a hatchery
in Huck's main base now sending in the
throne try to build a hatchery
clutch cruelty oh if oh it's not
necessary and there's the good game
Israel lived in Korea at the time and
travelled to attend foreign events while
Huck was based in North America but Huck
made the move to Korea beginning a
series of encounters between the two
players on ladder and further pushing
their rivalry stalkers now blink again
they are going to go to work out those
three Lords great storms going down on
the units of Indra Indra needs to pull
back gidran ruffling but I'm sure knots
and Happiness all those units dying very
quickly in removing in Indra a little
bit unhappy about the results of this
game and he does leave it pup continue
to use unconventional strategies like
cannon rush cheese against Indra on a
ladder
Indra for his part made it clear that he
had a distaste for Protoss flavors now
he's a piece of trash who wouldn't win
any games if you didn't fight Protoss
a little too BM there and there next
Lana meeting
MLG Dallas 2011 featured one of the most
infamous moments in their rivalry facing
off in the group stage
Indra took game 1 against Huck and it
looked like he would have game 2 as well
he built up like considerable lead and
was just one good engagement away from a
win but it relate game army had one
major weakness it wasn't terribly
effective against air units like void
rays which interest suddenly found
himself facing down now out on the field
that it looks like there's some
certainly soon a counter-attack in the
main the void Ray's all hallucinations
doing absolutely no damage whatsoever
there's to blink up onto the high ground
just trying to distract aedra those
hallucinating void rays almost fully
charged wheat and Edra left the game oh
my goodness Edra just take a look at
this we saw the stalkers come up here
start to target fire these brood Lords
and if you look down here there's only a
couple of stalkers and a ton of
centuries that would have died oh so
quick to that including their ability to
take out those colossi right there all
the rest of the stalkers were over on
that ramp trying to get back around and
as supply is actually a higher for it
row a little bit of a blunder there by
adran not actually playing it out to the
very end losing to hallucinate employed
raise so we will be going on the final
three Game three Wow yeah
that was pretty amazing right there the
unit's might not have been real but
Hawks victory was and a Huck wanted an
injury to know it so he told him in the
next game and got a predictable response
let me give some propped up to Huck I
mean that was very very smart uh
well oh man you know what Starcraft is
not only a very intensive mental game
but it could be psychological as well
while Huck won the battle taking that
serious injury won the war after the
group stage they faced off again with
Indra winning four to two and after the
event he couldn't pass up the chance to
talk more [ __ ] about how so Huck can't
win in a real game stand by your guns on
that one how good did it feel to knock
him off after the games yesterday
I mean I jerk and say what he wants he
likes to talk and lie a lot
I remember in a previous interview he
said he beats me all the time when
realistically the last 40 games we've
played he's won maybe five see just
sometimes a cocky hit and all this other
[ __ ] so you know I tried to be nice I
just want to continue doing whatever
he's doing that's fine with me I don't
care
and while Huff did eventually gets a
better of aedra winds at homestory cup 3
and the North American Blizzard
Invitational put huck on the board
the latter victory denying his opponent
a spot at Blizzcon hut there is lemonade
Sidra that means we have to Team Liquid
players in the top three Indra one of
the big favorites to win this event is
eliminated in fourth place and my August
the rivalry took an even stranger turn
puck left team liquid to join Evil
Geniuses turning him in is reformed
rival two teammates they played up in
the promotional stuff about you versus
Hawk and his big rivalry thing how much
was it really a like a rivalry of like
dislike before for you when he was in
like other teams we never disliked each
other personally we always got on pretty
well
pretty good friends even before he
joined eg but ice didn't respect his
plane very much and kind of said so but
he's improved a lot obviously he's been
practicing really hard three or four a
long time so yeah there's no pressure at
all there anymore
unable to weaponize their fan bases in
the same way as they used to that was
pretty much the end of Huck and Andrews
rivalry Edra continue to talk shed of
course he just directed as other players
after Huck join eg and after eventually
quitting Starcraft 2 in mid 2013 Indra
had a very brief stint in heroes of the
storm we're presenting eg in the game is
very first Blizzcon appear honestly a
lot calmer playing heroes of the storm
the biggest thing is it's a team game
and it's like purely a team game it's
the opposite and the spectrum from brood
war all that matters is how well you
work with your team and like the
strategy the thinking portion of the
game and if you get pissed off and like
you start raging then that affects your
teammates recently it revealed that he
hasn't owned a computer in some time and
these days he's mostly focused on
fitness no I haven't owned functioning
desktop in like two years now I was just
a really competitive person and
Starcraft happen to be the competition
that's stuck and now I don't know I was
kind of an angry competitor so I don't
know how healthy it is so I kind of
don't compete anymore right I think
weightlifting kind of filled that role
for me but no the Starcraft was just a
way to beat people and talk meanwhile
has successfully transitioned into
overwatch where he started as a caster
and has since become the president of
gaming for the Kraft group which owes
the Boston uprising one player has left
eSports behind and the other is helping
build a new pro scene but for just under
two years
well the Western Starcraft 2 fanbase was
looking for heroes and villains Adria
and Hough gave them exactly what they
needed one a foul-mouthed confident
veteran you're kind of notorious for
being a little bit bad manner
and me knowing you personally I would
say that's that might be based in some
truth what were your thoughts on that
game
I aspire really short and sweet the
other a fresh-faced new hope who knew
how to play to the crowd
just thank you I mean I think I have the
best fans in the world and I love you
guys and I'm glad you enjoyed my games
and despite the rivalry being
short-lived the intensity of the two
players and the passion of their fans
made their conflict one to remember the
point raised all hallucinations doing
absolutely no damage whatsoever there's
the blink up onto the high ground just
trying to distract Indra those
hallucinating boys raised almost only
charge sweet and it left the game thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button